remoras nature's underwater hitchhikers
hold on tight
the jumping dolphins boat hauls even
divers also called Suckerfish their
amazing grip comes from an adhesive disc
made from a modified dorsal fin on the
fish's head so obviously the question is
could a robot be designed to hold on
this tight underwater to different
surfaces making something that works
like a remoras disc will help us better
understand how they work and could one
day lead to useful underwater devices
based on the same principles researchers
took up the challenge and designed a
biomimetic Remora disc like the fish's
specialized sucker it can make a seal
and has rows of flaps dotted with tiny
spikes that allow it to raise and lower
the area under the seal to see how well
the sucker worked
the researchers attached it to a remote
control submarine and tested out its
capabilities on average the sucker
grabbed onto plexiglass and shark skin
in less than four seconds and held on
tight once stuck it took 45 kilograms of
force to remove it that's about 340
times the weight of the prototype sucker
it also stayed sticky outside of the
water as well in the future researchers
hope to see similar suction systems used
anywhere strong adhesion is needed and
at some point used to extend the range
of robotic submarines
[Music]